J'ai vu la fin du monde, je pouvais sentir
toute cette mort Jeanne, c'était juste un
rêve, on
m'a appelé beaucoup de choses au cours de nombreuses
vies en essayant de
raaah krishna yahweh depuis que le
monde a découvert les mutants, il y a
eu des sociétés secrètes qui les voient comme
une sorte de seconde venue ou un signe de
Dieu, ils croient qu'il y a des dizaines de milliers
d'années, un être ancien est né
le premier mutant du monde vous êtes tous mes
enfants et ils ont perdu
parce que vous suivez des dirigeants aveugles
mais je suis ici maintenant je suis là pour toi
où que soit cet être, il a toujours eu 4
disciples qu'il imprègnerait de pouvoir comme
les Quatre Cavaliers de l'Apocalypse, il a
obtenu celui-là de la Bible ou la Bible l'a
obtenu de lui
qu'est-ce que c'est Oh mon Dieu,
il peut nous contrôler tous,
le monde a besoin du  x-men c'est pourquoi je suis
ici pour me battre,
nous ne pouvons pas tous contrôler nos pouvoirs,
alors ce n'est pas la guerre,
tout ce qu'ils ont construit
tombera et des cendres de leur
monde en construira un meilleur que
je n'ai jamais ressenti comme le pouvoir  ceci avant
toi